i think that the american identity is so
fractured because of current day
politics that there's almost no such
thing as a movie that everybody can get
behind
i think the most recent example of one
was
why do you love movies so much
i
feel like i love movies because it's
like it's like a waking dream right it's
it's a it's a dream and an experience
where
you can
you know
enter the mind of a character and
experience the world through their eyes
and it's
it's actually safe
right whether that character
you know
um gets horribly injured
has
terrible things happen to them or loses
you know loved ones friends family
members
you're you're able to experience those
things the kinds of things that
everybody experiences in life in a way
that's safe
and in a way that imparts lessons
whether you're aware of it at the time
or not there's something in our lizard
brain that responds to storytelling
because i i think it's
it's it's a way for us to exercise our
own demons or to deal with
loss and pain from our past
and that's why i think storytelling and
in particular movies
and in particular movies and seeing a
movie in a theater when it's dark and
you're focused and you're not on your
phone you're not distracted although i
will say there is an entire category of
movies that i would say this would be a
good movie to watch while you're folding
laundry
and i have watched those movies
and i have folded laundry while i've
watched them but the
a film i know i'm really going to care
about i'm going to see in a theater in
the dark experience the world through
that character's eyes and
and
come out the other end better for it
and
it's so universal that feeling
that feeling that's why you know
wherever you go in the world
people people love
to
you know have us have a story unfold on
the big screen i think there's something
primal about that that goes back to
telling stories around the campfire or
just a fire
right there's there's something about it
that's just embedded in our heads and
that's why you know
the love and passion for film is so
universal worldwide
and when did you find that category of
the folding laundry film
i i think the folding laundry film came
during the pandemic
in terms of
watching stuff i probably would not have
watched otherwise
when it's just well
we're here there's no movies at the
theater i'm gonna watch this thing and
so i think there is an entire category
of movies and a lot of uh i would say
series television where
you can get a lot of the story that is
happening just from the it's just from
hearing it so it's kind of an a radio
play
and they say that the original star trek
series if you're not watching it if
you're just listening to it and i can
confirm this because when i was a kid i
used to record the audio of old episodes
of star trek and listen to them and even
though i wasn't seeing everything when i
would listen to those cassette tapes
later
i still got
got the story
you know all of your narrative points
your
your character moments you know your
drama from the music
uh there there's a whole
world uh
of just like just that that you can
experience just from listening to it
and i i would i would recommend just um
as an exercise for fun some of the
content on streaming services like
netflix you can get not just the
captions on but there's a thing called
audio description
and i strongly recommend that you do
this try this out for fun
take something you like if audio
description is an option that's
available it's for people who are
disabled
may not be able to see
and not only do you hear the dialogue
you hear a description of a narrator
telling you what has is happening
action-wise on the screen it's it's in a
way almost like having the screenplay
read to you
it's
it's i mean
it obviously has a function
uh a useful function for people who are
are unable to see
but it also
as as a way of learning
you know you you can you can listen to
these heck you can listen to them while
you're driving and you get the entire
story the audio descriptive version
there's even
you can look this up online there's
there are people who list some of the
best audio descriptive versions of
content
so
i i find it really useful i think it's
interesting but the folding laundry yes
i think we've all had that experience
where you're like
uh
this thing that i'm about to watch
doesn't deserve all of my attention for
me it's generally romantic comedies i
romantic comedies
as much as i am sometimes forced to
watch them
i feel like that's
that's something i can multitask and
still enjoy
okay so suppose tonight is laundry night
so after this interview i'm gonna you
know go down to the laundromat and then
i'm gonna come back
and start folding and organizing can you
recommend two movies for me oh sure uh
i
marry me
with jennifer lopez which i saw recently
that's a totally uh a full laundry movie
and uh i would say death on the nile
for
recent films okay they may not be recent
when you're watching this i have no idea
when you're watching this when are you
watching this i don't know
all right great
i want to do laundry right now check
them out
but we all know we have those right
everyone where you're just like this is
like my full attention is going on this
christopher nolan movie or whatever it
is we're seeing like i you know
i'm gonna turn off the lights and i have
my little i have like this uh sort of
led like blue light that goes around my
television kind of kind of makes a movie
theater experience in 4k whatever but
then there's other things where you're
like now i'm just going to have this on
in the background or for me it's even a
movie i've seen so many times i can
quote the entire film
or what's great is when you think you're
going to watch a film like that and
you're actually surprised like i was
watching old episodes do you remember
vr5 no i don't remember oh okay so it
had lori singer and it was about her um
she had this gift of being able to go
into virtual reality and she was the
only one that had this ability and so
she was being like
wanted by big tech at that time which
was in the mid 90s and it the
storytelling was excellent you know it's
got cool old graphics and modems but
i thought oh this is the perfect thing
to put on and actually
i couldn't do anything else right right
like some of those you put on thinking
like ah whatever i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna organize my
receipts right okay that's something
here to do you put something on and then
you do get caught up i mean that's
that's a pleasant surprise but but i
kind of plan my viewing that way because
i tend to watch
at least a movie a day if not more
it's just it's part of what i do
what does an american film mean today
i really think that
there is no american cinema today the
last great era of american cinema was in
the 70s and probably the 80s as well
but um i think that the american
identity is so fractured because of
current day politics that there's almost
no such thing as a movie that everybody
can get behind
i think the most recent example of one
was
the latest spider-man movie spider-man
no way home which was a
an incredibly fun
like
spider-man not just a spider-man movie
it's a spider-man movie that was built
up over 20 years of spider-man movie
fandom starting with toby mcguire
[Music]
andrew garfield
you know and and building up to this
where now that all the spider men are
are united that was like hey we can all
get behind this you know it's a
completely fun superhero movie ride
we can all get behind it is that an
american film
i don't know i would argue that the
superhero genre is something that's very
american made
but i really feel we've lost our
identity
as a country because it's so fractured
into
multiple different americas
uh
and
i'll i'll give you an example this is a
weird thing i did i did a panel
at a a convention called politicon and i
pitched a panel called trump the movie
and i had a friend of mine who was a
screenwriter i had a friend of mine who
worked in film development and i asked
like you know almost every president
post
their presidency has a movie made about
them right not a documentary a dramatic
movie that you know sort of goes through
the highlights the low lights and you
know
and and i wondered if if
a trump movie would ever be made
how would you market that movie
and i got it was a very interesting
discussion because we got into this
whole thing of like okay
you make the movie whatever the movie is
what kind of movie would it be would it
be more comedic would it be sort of
farcical
you know like maybe
maybe like from the mind of adam mckay
or something like that you know like
like what would it be one but then here
becomes the challenge of marketing that
movie which comes back to the question
of american cinema okay you've made a
movie about the trump presidency
who is it for and how do you market it
do you do a marketing campaign that is
for uh the red states
that makes trump look like a hero
do you do another campaign
another marketing campaign from the same
movie
that talks about how he's a horrible
human being
and this one these are the trailers you
would run in the blue states i think it
would be really interesting to see
which is why i think a movie like that
will not be made
i don't think that there'll be a
dramatic
telling of his story
of of the trump presidency it's just not
going to happen and i think it has to do
with our fractured america that's why we
have no uh
really cohesive
american cinema
i think that there are outside interests
um and the concerns of our corporate
factory filmmaking
are that this movie needs to play
globally
so it it's again and i've talked about
this many times the check boxes that
need to go
you know in order for something to play
to the world
means that you've you've kind of
distilled it and and it's not really a
holy american
uh american movie and the only way you
would notice this is if you watched a
lot of foreign uh foreign films or or
what they call now world cinema so i
would say to you
i i say as an exercise for yourself
watch a canadian movie
watch a canadian it's very canadian and
you know the
a lot of countries actually subsidize
their
filmmakers and and the arts
um and in particular is the canadian
film board that you pitch a movie to the
canadian film board has to have a
certain percentage of canadian talent in
it
large percentage it has to have canadian
themes and made for people in canada
and there are a lot of things
you know if you're watching this you're
american you're not going to get the
jokes
i grew up
in michigan
just outside of of canada
and uh and so i experience the cbc i
watch canadian children's programming
i watch canadian movies i watch canadian
hockey i became a hockey fan from
watching the cbc but it's really
interesting to see how distinct
the american identity is to the
canadian
canadian culture
so do yourself a favor and watch
see films from other countries and
you'll notice how important it is for
those countries to
to lay out their identity in their
culture in particular french cinema
does that as well
so i'd say broaden your horizons broaden
your media diet and you'll just notice
that most of the movies that are made in
america now are not for america they're
for the globe
they just are and so
i think what's happened is it's eroded
our identity as americans or something
we could get behind because like i said
you're going to make a movie about trump
you're going to have two marketing
campaigns for that movie no matter what
that movie ends up being
well let's suppose we just take the name
trump out of it we could use any
president really in the last let's say
20 years we could use
any media figures in the last few years
if we were to have a trailer that was
specific to their audience wouldn't it
be almost considered propaganda
well i would say that
at least when it comes to
to documentaries it's almost all
propaganda now
i mean i i would say to documentary
filmmakers it's just like i i i see a
lot of docs
small indie docs um that come to film
threat for us to look at
and it's almost all
solidly on one side of the equation or
the other i've seen
you know
pro-trump documentaries i've seen
anti-trump documentaries i would say
that the only one that was truly
unbiased was made by a british filmmaker
called the accidental president oh yes i
heard of that yeah and i strongly
recommend the accidental president it's
um
it's just one because it's made by a
brit is just like look
got no skin in the game
you know let's let's look at trump as a
person and and what he did and it was
it's it's really fascinating because i
think it's an it's an unbiased look at
that at his run for the presidency but
really most political documentaries i
see now they're either i i can already
tell it's like oh
team red team blue where where where
what happened to being unbiased what
happened to being a journalist and
seeking out truth no matter where it
leads you know that used to be the way
things were
not sure what happened to that um you
know and i've often said
film threat
mymediaoutlet filmthreat.com where we
review independent films we're
politically agnostic we have people on
all sides
um
you know on all different
diversities of thought i think is my
more
what takes priority with me
um and i i do enjoy reading someone
whose opinion doesn't completely line up
with mine it's an opportunity to to
learn something but i but i really see a
fracture in in the world of doc
filmmaking where most
of what's being produced is
purely propaganda
you know um there was a
and and to be clear my politics are very
middle of the road
you know sure i i can sit here and talk
to you all day about star wars
and star wars is actually a good place
i'm sure we'll get to some star wars
talk star wars a good place because it's
a thing that
most people have seen 99.9 of people
have seen it so it's a great entry point
to talk about lots of issues
um that particular movie or film series
and all that it begat um
but
but boy we we've really gotten to a
place now where
i just have concerns about we've lost
the ability to objectively look at facts
and
i think that's lazy
here's why it bothers me it's lazy
because
just as someone who's politically been
in the middle which means i
generally despise both sides
you know i think that
let's come up with solutions to problems
and if you're focused on the solution it
really
really shouldn't matter necessarily your
the politics or
what you may be compromised by when it
comes to your donors but i but um now i
feel that if you are on one side or the
other i feel that that in my opinion is
kind of lazy because what what it says
is the thinking is done for you
which is why i think there are many ways
to look at an issue so
i would just like to see documentary
filmmaker filmmaking become
less less biased
i think i think that would be a great
service to all of us